t'es fait chez nous par bombardier avait
co c'est dans le contexte du choc
pétrolier de 1973 que bombardier
diversifie ses activités et mise sur le
transport sur rail peu fortuné maire
drapeau un moment donné mais raconte
wendy écoute
vous deviez soumissionner sur métro de
montréal faisant et finalement on a
rapporté le contremaître moria premier
gros contrat fabriquer 423 voitures de
métro pour montréal qui accueille les
jeux olympiques début des années 80
entreprises commencent à se mondialiser
et construit des usines à l'étranger
dont une au vermont ce qui lui permet
d'obtenir un contrat déterminant la
fourniture de 825 voitures pour le métro
de new york
tec est capable russell métronome les
termes mon panier international
finalement des menus de ville au mondial
grâce à ce succès pour mardi décroche
plusieurs contrats majeurs dans d'autres
villes nord-américaines dont toronto et
vancouver
les années 80 90 sont marquées par des
acquisitions de filiales et d'entreprise
ferroviaire qui permettent à bombardier
de percer les marchés européens avec
leurs routines l emploi au début des
années 2000 c'est l'une des plus grosses
transactions de bombardier elle acquiert
la filiale à outrance de daimler
chrysler puis déménage son siège social
de montréal vers berlin
les trains de bombardier roule
aujourd'hui aux quatre coins de la
planète en chine en australie à dubaï et
new delhi
mais tout n'est pas au beau fixe pour
l'entreprise qui a du mal à respecter
ces délais plusieurs contrats
connaissent des problèmes dans la
livraison et baigne dans la contreverse
bombardier connaît des ratés en
allemagne en suisse à londres à new york
et à toronto pour ne nommer que ceux là
l'avenir de bombardier transport est
maintenant entre les mains de son ancien
compétiteur alstom ici julie aimant
radio canada montréal